[Music]
months of protest
in belarus an armed battle between
azerbaijan and armenia
a violent uprising after a disputed
parliamentary election in kyrgyzstan
tensions in these former soviet
republics have mounted despite vladimir
putin's efforts to keep control and
bring back stability
weakened by the economic impact of the
pandemic moscow has fewer resources to
spend on the upkeep of military outposts
in countries like armenia or kyrgyzstan
and its power in the region is waning
russia's
dominant position is no longer really
dominant
and it's increasingly challenged by
regional powers moscow is spending
on military forces troops in the regions
that it cares about
like in armenia azerbaijan kyrgyzstan
countries of the former soviet union but
right now what's priority for russia
is ensuring that it pumps money
into its economy in order to keep people
satisfied
as competitors like china and turkey are
expanding their presence in the region
30 years after the end of the soviet
union russia's monopoly on power in its
former territories
is under threat
russia has maintained strong
relationships with former soviet
republics
and even pushed to deepen economic and
military ties in recent years
belarus kyrgyzstan and armenia have been
part of the eurasian economic union
single market since 2015
and russian forces are also stationed in
belarus armenia and kyrgyzstan
but other countries have also invested
money and increased military cooperation
in that region
turkey for example has thrown its
military support behind azerbaijan in
the conflict with armenia
a close russian ally in the disputed
region of nagorno-karabakh
russia has good relations both with
armenia and azerbaijan
and actually sells weapons to both of
these countries
and it's a way of balancing the
influence in the region
wary of taking sides russia wants to
play a role as mediator in the conflict
and helped armenia and azerbaijan reach
a temporary ceasefire
but fighting is continued and both sides
are accusing each other of violating the
truce agreements
highlighting the limits of russia's
power turkey's involvement is putting
pressure on russia to protect its
armenian ally
but analysts say moscow wants to avoid a
broader conflict
and russia doesn't want to get involved
because it doesn't have too many
resources
in kyrgyzstan clashes between political
factions have been driven by local
conflicts
and claims of rigged elections beyond
calling it chaos
the kremlin hasn't officially supported
either party
russia has taken a very kind of more
relaxed
hands-off approach to the conflict in
that region
the pro-russian president resigned days
after meeting with his nationalist
opponent with the mediation of putin's
senior aides
but in this country where russia has a
military base
another superpower has expanded its
presence in recent years
china shares a border with kyrgyzstan
and has invested heavily in
infrastructure as part of its initiative
known as belt and road
russia is very aware of the kind of
influence that beijing could have in
central asia and in a country like
kyrgyzstan
russia can take this laid-back approach
but it realizes that it still needs to
show that it cares
about kyrgyzstan because the instant it
shows that it does not care china could
easily move in and have more of an
influence there than russia would care
for it to have
in belarus it's a different story
protests have continued for months
but that doesn't mean russia isn't in
control
[Music]
president alexander lukashenko is
holding on to power despite accusations
of a rigged election
as pressure has mounted on his
presidency he's accepted russia's
demands to discuss new military bases
and trade agreements
even as belarus already relies heavily
on russia for crude
in oil short to medium term russia is
actually winning
because with the regime be deeply
wounded
it looks like belarus moving much closer
towards
russia on the other hand moscow has
avoided expressing clear support for
lukashenko
suggesting that it doesn't want to
estrange belarusians
some of whom have called for the
european union to intervene
the kremlin is very conscious of that by
siding
with mr lukashenko russia actually risks
alienating the biela russian people and
that's a huge risk for russia
so rise of regional powers and the lure
of european unions west
china in the east and then turkey and
south caucasus is really
a daunting challenge for russia after
two decades of aggressive military
campaigns
in countries like georgia and ukraine
putin's approach to foreign policy in
russia's backyard has shifted
as he prepares to potentially remain in
power until 2036
the russian president is himself under
pressure to revitalize his country's
waning economy while fighting the
pandemic
president putin has seen protests in the
far east
people are dissatisfied people have lost
their jobs because of coronavirus and he
needs to show his population
that the priority is here at home and
the priority
isn't pumping money into foreign
escapades